bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être ce matin en direct sur rt france
nos enfants sont ils bien éduqué on a
choisi intentionnellement ce terme est
éduqué car on ne peut pas parler de
l'enseignement sans y inclure évidemment
la responsabilité des parents on va en
parler mais d'abord ces critiques du
personnel enseignant qui dénonce jeu si
des réformes empilées qui dessinent
encore un peu plus une école une école
inégalitaire
céline inac quel bilan faites vous de
l'action du gouvernement
nous avons essayé de justement nous
rendre cette école au contraire plus
égalitaire avec pour la réforme fin on
en reparle dans l'éducation prioritaire
avec le dédoublement des dcp décevants
et des grandes sections c'est donc on
agit justement pour que l'école soit
plus égalitaire donner plus de moyens là
où
les difficultés se
concentrent aux autres grandes réformes
qui a été celle de la mise en place des
sites et éducative les sites et
éducative se sont que des endroits
particulièrement en zone d'éducation
prioritaire en lien avec les quartiers
prioritaires de la ville où il y a eu un
développement de tout le réseau autour
des établissements scolaires lycées
collèges primaires avec le tissu
associatif avec les élus locaux avec
également par exemple la police
nationale ou la gendarmerie
locale avec les pompiers en fête avec
tous les secteurs qui peuvent justement
participer à l'éducation des enfants
alors on va en parler alexis ville peu
les mêmes question pensez vous que les
mesures du gouvernement vont dans le bon
sens justement pour aplanir en tout cas
ces inégalités à l'école mais attendez
les mesures du gouvernement les
enseignants font crs parmi les moins
bien payés d'europe
la violence est partout présente et
aussi on n'a toujours pas nous ce qu'on
réclame depuis des années on n'a
toujours pas rétabli un vrai
apprentissage du français nous ce qu'on
propose c'est 15 heures de cours par
semaine pour les primaires revenir ce
qui se passait dans les années 60 70 à
une époque on apprenait réellement le
français apprendre le français à tron de
raconter après les mathématiques 50% du
temps d'évoluer france et 25% du temps
dévolu
matic voilà ça ça nous paraît très
important revenir sur les fondamentaux
approfondir les fondamentaux et cesser
les expérimentations hasardeuses des
pédagogistes ont donc revaloriser le
cerf des professeurs nous ce qu'on
propose c'est revaloriser le salaire pas
le doublé comme madame hidalgo ce n'est
pas réaliste mais le revaloriser devant
devant % et je reviens là dessus il est
fondamental que le rétablir l'autorité
du professeur rétablir l'autorité du
conseil de classe donc en grand en tout
cela nous estimons que même s'il ya des
mesures est à quelques mois de
l'élection présidentielle
un peu comme le mauvais élève qui se
réveille au dernier moment pour bûcher
on voit ça beaucoup d'un gouvernement ça
reste très largement sérieusement selon
vous le dédoublement des classes c'est
une bonne mesure annoncée est une bonne
chose ça c'était dans ça je reconnais
que c'est une bonne mesure ça
effectivement ça y'a pas de doute là
dessus mais néanmoins tout le reste il
aurait fallu en fait monsieur blanc
caire a donné une
autre débute monsieur blanc caire avait
l'air de prendre des bonnes décisions de
revenir sur les étals désastreux de
madame vallaud belkacem et après il a
été totalement mis sous la coupe réglée
d'une cette influence pédagogistes et on
n'a plus du tout entendu on a eu
vraiment trois premiers mois
intéressante michel blanquer après plus
rien le vix le vide intersidéral on va
parler de ce que propose justement les
candidats pour un pur pour la
présidentielle on va d'abord écouté
voulant vous en avait parlé à mme
hidalgo qui elle va doubler le salaire
des enseignants
une mesure qui a déjà été critiquée par
vous et par jean-luc mélenchon regarder
rock'n'roll hidalgo elle veut doubler et
même plus le salaire des enseignants ça
fait plus de 60 milliards par an moi je
préfère satisfaire les demandes des
syndicats enseignants et mettre le
paquet sur les créations de postes le ps
a aussi perdu sa culture du gouvernement
alors c'est sillery lacunes une réaction
est ce que c'est en augmentant le
salaire des professeurs qu'ils vont être
plus performant
c'est pas en augmentant salaires des
professeurs qui aurait pu faire formant
est par contre c'est extrêmement
important d'avoir une augmentation des
salaires des enseignants
particulièrement les plus jeunes parce
qu'aujourd'hui lorsque vous avez un
master et que en effet vous débutez à un
métier aux alentours de 700 euros par
mois c'est pas le métier le plus
attractif et nous avons besoin de
redonner de l'attractivité à notre asso
à ce très beau métier donc il faut ré
hausser le salaire des enseignants mais
là où madame hidalgo en effet commis une
erreur c'est que rond tout le monde sait
que c'est complètement utopique de
doubler l'objectif
ça serait comme l'a dit d'ailleurs
jean-michel noquet reparaître par
exemple d'atteindre au moins les 2000
euros par mois pour les jeunes
enseignants ensuite il ya toute la
gestion des carrières aujourd'hui il
faut aussi que les enseignants mais là
je parle de motivation d'entretenir la
motivation des enseignants il faut aussi
que les enseignants soient valorisés
dans le travail lorsque vous avez des
enseignants qui sont investis dans leur
établissement que ce soit dans le
premier degré ou donc de second degré eh
bien il faudrait qu'ils puissent
bénéficier de la qualité
d'investissement auprès de leurs élèves
de justement peut-être au niveau
salarial et là je ne parle pas de
contrat d'objectifs comme on a entendu
dire que ce n'est pas sur la réussite
des élèves qu'on évalue un enseignant
parce que ça c'est très variable sur le
territoire non c'est bien d'évaluer de
voir quand on risque un enseignant met
ses compétences au service de la
réussite des élèves quelle qu'elle soit
c'est pas aux examens forcément que l'on
réussit bien je fais une petite
parenthèse je reviens sur la réforme du
lycée on parle justement où toujours
d'inégalités le fait d'avoir mis au
baccalauréat un grand oral là aussi
c'est une mesure assez égalitaire parce
que aujourd'hui on sait très bien qu'il
ya des élèves qui ont énormément roue
mal pour s'exprimer à l'écrit travailler
l'oral pour tous c'est quelque chose qui
est beaucoup plus dans notre société
moderne quelque chose d'intéressant donc
là c'est la parenthèse
également donc vous voyez il ya encore
beaucoup de choses à faire et je vous
rappellerai simplement que nous avons
dernier budget augmenter de 400 mille
mignon le le budget de l'éducation
nationale ça sera à 500 cette année
oui 700 membres et de manière à ce qu'il
y ait une augmentation à la fois des
salaires mais aussi cette année la
création d'un espace de communautés
d'entreprises qui permettent la de
toucher au pouvoir d'achat des
enseignants c'est à dire de leur faire
bénéficier de services qu'on les
entreprises communes participer à des
sorties participer à d'autres choses qui
ne touche pas uniquement le salaire une
réaction alexis ville plaie je voudrais
aussi vous réagissiez amont à ce
problème des jeunes enseignants dont on
parlait d'un an dont on parlait salaire
jusqu'à présent ces jeunes ces jeunes
enseignants qui sont envoyées dans l'est
dans les zones difficiles est ce qu'il
ne faudrait pas changer cela aussi bien
sûr c'est le sait le problème c'est
qu'ils évidemment où l'on voit les ans
ce jeune enseignant dans des zones
difficiles ça évidemment c'est pas de la
faute aux actuels cessé depuis plus
longtemps il faudrait créer un système
de tutorat beaucoup plus fort entre les
des anciens et des nouveaux enseignants
mais ça effectivement il faut le il faut
leur et il faut le changer mais au-delà
de ça mais là vous touchez un problème
plus global food ou chez un gros le
problème des quartiers le preuve de la
simulation dans les quartiers et ça
c'est un le problème de l'autorité de la
république de façon générale et du
professeur de façon particulière donc ça
effectivement
c'est plein de mines c'est un énorme
sujet sur lequel il faut il faut il
qu'il faut prendre entre on prend pas le
taureau par les cornes mais c'est un
c'est à la fois une question d'éducation
de l'instruction publique et à la fois
une question
d'assimilation de façon générale dans
les quartiers parce que il faut
retrouver un respect de l'ordre un
respect de la de la république et elle
c'est pour ça qu'il faut monter il faut
un changement complet de paradigme
réellement afin que les plus jeunes et
le respect de l'autorité de façon
générale sur votre question toucher les
jeunes d'enseignants oui effectivement
il faudrait valoriser parce
qu'actuellement quand vous êtes un jeune
en professeur six touchés un duel un
smic et le problème c'est que c'est pas
comme ça que vous allez attirer les
meilleurs malheureusement à une époque
où le cas pour avoir son capes de
français de mathématiques les notes
moyennes soit 5 ou 6 sur 20
être admissible
voit bien que malheureusement il ya
évidemment de très beaux professeurs
mais on n'attire plus les meilleurs donc
il faut d'urgence revaloriser les
salaires mais vous savez les en
allemagne au luxembourg
on est quasiment
oneda des salaires deux fois supérieure
alors bonne foi nous contrairement à
madame hidalgo ne propose pas deux fois
supérieure aux trousses une hausse de
20% est également une potentielle hausse
supplémentaire pour les enseignants qui
serait disponible pour faire des cours
de soutien ça nous pas extrêmement
important d'offrir la possibilité à la
fois aux élèves en discuter et à la fois
aux enseignants s'ils veulent travailler
plus pour gagner plus de pouvoir
effectuer des cours de soutien dans
l'enceinte du collège du cdu même du
primaire est ainsi un voit un complément
de revenu alors michel barnier candidat
à l'investiture les républicains lui
veut faire de l'éducation une grande une
grande cause nationale regarder
je propose que l'éducation devienne la
grande cause nationale du prochain
quinquennat il faut se concentrer sur
les devoirs fondamentaux en primaire
pour aller librement il faut savoir d'où
l'on vient il faudra concevoir les
programmes d'histoire en revenant à un
arrachement chronologique du récit
national
cécile à une réaction savoir d'où l'on
vient
refaire de l'histoire de façon
chronologique qu'en pensez vous
ce que dit monsieur malabar nié tout le
monde est d'accord - la première de dire
il faut que ça devienne une priorité
nationale mais après c'est aussi ce que
monsieur ville plaide le disais tout à
l'heure
tout le monde regarde en arrière et
regarde ce qui a été fait non c'est pas
en regardant derrière en se disant il
faut 15 heures de français il faut
revenir un roman national il que les
l'éducation et le système éducatif va
s'améliorer il faut au contraire
regarder vers l'avant regarder vers
l'avenir il faut pouvoir s'arrêter et
regarder en arrière pour le français
c'est pas faux la majorité beaucoup
d'élèves
étaient non et par regarder en arrière
parce qu'il ya quand même quelques
petites erreurs qui auraient été qui ont
été commises il faut savoir que
lorsqu'on regarde en arrière il y avait
à une époque seulement 25 % de nos
élèves qui avaient le bac aujourd'hui
ses 80 % d'élèves qui ont bac donc
lorsqu'on lorsqu'on veut démocratiser
oui monsieur l'île pelée c'est 80 %
quand on fait tous les bac bac
professionnel bac technologique et bac
général vous en laisse en outre il faut
bien dire puisque je veux qu'on
travaille pour l'égalité des jeunes et
qu'on veut qu'il y ait une élévation
générale du niveau eh bien on s'arrache
à ne pas laisser justement trop de
jeunes sur le trottoir et donc on veut
faire avancer tout le monde donc oui
immédiat les recettes qui fonctionnent
mais lacombe est donc terminée donc il
faut qu'il y ait un petit peu plus en
effet de moyens qu'ils soient donnés à à
l'école particulièrement vis-à-vis des
enseignants il faut aussi que nous
retravaillons que nous continuons à
travailler ce que nous avons fait depuis
quatre ans sur une école réellement
inclusive c'est à dire que tous les
enfants puissent bénéficier de notre
système éducatif
et quitte à ce que derrière il est une
orientation choisie et non plus subi
parce que ça aussi c'est l'un des
grosses difficultés de notre système
actuel nous avons aussi en france une
société qui est basé sur le diplôme et
il faut peut-être un certain moment se
poser la question sur quelles sont les
valeurs justement de nos diplômes par
rapport à ce qu attendent justement le
milieu du travail et il ya peut-être des
interconnexions à faire un petit peu
plus importante que ce soit dans le
secondaire ou même dans le supérieur de
manière à ce que les formations puissent
être en adéquation avec une future
insertion professionnelle tu as une
réforme que nous n'avons pas réussi à
faire c'est celle de l'enseignement
professionnel c'est-à-dire de
revaloriser tout aussi les métiers
techniques et les métiers manuels ouais
ça pose la question de l'ue de fans au
collège unique je laisse répondre à
alexis villepelet non mais je suis
stupéfait de vous entendre donc vous
pour vous 15 heures de français par
semaine c'est pas une bonne idée pour en
primaire mon dieu c'est ce qui marchait
dans les années 50 60 et même sur la
troisième république c'est l'école qui
avait permis le les fondements la
république qui permettait l'ascension
sociale qui permettait de justifier de
justifier l'impôt on avait vraiment une
belle école qui fonctionne et on se
souvient des hussards noirs de la
république jusque dans les années 50-60
ç'a fonctionné parce qu'on apprenait le
français parce qu'on apprenait à compter
moi je suis toujours stupéfait de ces
personnes est ce qu est ce que vous
venez de faire madame quelque chose qui
fonctionne on le jette à la poubelle
mais si ça fonctionne ou le garde ça
fonctionne on le conserve 6 15 heures de
15 heures de français par semaine ça
fonctionnait il vous a pas échappé que
dans tous les classements
dans tous les classements sur les
français les mathématiques la france est
en train de s'effondrer la france a fait
une belle école la france a été célèbre
la france était un hôtel européen en
terme d'écoles et vous voulez tout jeter
non effectivement il faut pas vivre dans
le passé il faut pas vivre dans le passé
c'est vrai mais quand les choses qui
marchent et là on les conserve oui
réponse c'est cela qu'on a l'impression
de l'élévation générale que vous prônez
c'est au détriment peut-être de faire
baisser le niveau de certains et
d'élever évidemment ce solide et
c'est là où la france a toujours été
très bonne c'est que nous avons su
garder justement les 1 % de nos très
bons élèves ils demeurent les meilleurs
même sur les classements internationaux
là-dessus il n'y a aucun aucun problème
si on prend vraiment dans le détail les
classements pisa la france forme
toujours eu une élite mais par contre là
où je dirais qu'il faut et ben regarde
fièrement des petits prime parce que
vous verrez que les meilleurs demeurent
les meilleurs il n'y a pas de souci
là-dessus que par contre lorsque vous
mentionnez
prenait 15 heures de français en pensant
juste la discipline français il faut
faire du rabâchage moi ce que je dis et
que certains d'ailleurs sont sortis
certains pédagogues que certains
enseignants disent c'est qu'on peut
faire du français 15 heures par semaine
en faisant en s'appuyant sur les autres
disciplines en faisant ce qu'on appelle
du transversale et c'est là où en effet
moi je tient pas un discours purement
idéologique en disant il faut faire 15
heures de français il faut faire 10
heures de maintenon moi ce que je ce que
nous on dit c'est qu'il faut revenir à
une transversalité des manières parce
que le français c'est pas simplement
faisant béaba et en fourrure récitant de
la grammaire que l'on peut apprendre on
peut faire du français à travers de
l'histoire on peut faire de faute il
nous reste un ver en sciences voilà il
reste peu de temps si les matières
fondamentales très importante a enseigné
d'une manière très forte et c'est ce que
jean michel blanquer a fait d'ailleurs
sur ces quatre dernières années mais en
s'appuyant aussi sur d'autres
disciplines de manière à pouvoir qu'à
comprendre aux élèves justement
l'intérêt de ses dc10 alors est ce vrai
que vous réagissiez sur une mesure qui
revient régulièrement dans le débat le
port de l'uniforme à l'école même jean
michel blanc car s'ils ne s'est pas
opposée finalement quel est votre
sentiment
alexis villepelet sur sur la question de
l'uniforme à l'école pour tout le monde
c'est le cas d'ailleurs dans les dom tom
ou des trésors et non il faut rêver il
faut y réfléchir moi je ne suis pas
certain que ce soit la priorité ça peut
être une solution pour tout vous dire on
y réfléchi à ça mais c'est peut-être pas
la priorité en revanche on parlait de
france est une priorité preixan c'est
d'arrêter des données naturelles
français et deux de sanctionner
réellement ce qui enseigne l'écriture
inclusive monsieur blanc car je le
reconnais s'était opposé à l'écriture
inclusive mais c'est une chose de
s'opposer et c'est une chose de faire
respecter cette opposition donc par
exemple c'est sont donnés dénaturer
notre notre belle langue non à
l'écriture inclusive et j'ai au maintien
la langue française langue française
elle est parlée par 600 millions
personnes ce qui est absurde c'est que
désormais vous allez les québécois on
sait mieux le français que nous les
québécois parlent mieux français que
nous c'est bien c'est bien très et trop
étonnant gardons notre notre belle
langue et surtout pas d'expand peut-être
pas d'expérimentations hasardeuses mené
par des pédagogistes à tendances
gauchistes comme l'écriture la crise a
vraiment c'est s'était pas de questions
je m'excuse mais c'est celle là qui nous
reste 10 secondes pour répondre à cette
question du port de l'uniforme
ses parents ne m'attendais unifiant dans
les écoles qu'on va régler les problèmes
d'inégalité ça j'en suis convaincu c'est
déjà possible side les aides dans les
projets d'établissement ce qu'ils
veulent en mettre ils en font parce que
derrière il ya aussi un problème qui
financent cet uniforme voilà donc pour
moi c'est pas un sujet de fond c'est
vraiment un sujet de forme merci
beaucoup à tous les deux merci d'avoir
débattue ce matin en direct dans la
matinale d arte france sur cette
question de l'éducation